today i'm going to be speaking with
spencer headworth who's assistant
professor of sociology at purdue
university affiliated scholar of the
american bar foundation and also author
of the book policing welfare punitive
adversarialism
in public assistance uh it's great to
have you on i really appreciate your
time
thanks for having me it's good to be
here so um you know i think maybe to get
us into this conversation oftentimes in
popular culture
people will point to
the ronald reagan stories about welfare
queens as really raising the level of
suspicion around welfare programs and
and so-called free riders
how far back can we trace that suspicion
about people receiving benefits they
don't really deserve in this type of
idea
sure uh so it goes back about as far as
organized poverty relief programs go
back so you can look at english poor law
in the 15th century in the 1400s in
england and in those very early versions
of assistance programs there were
provisions for
you know inspectors basically to check
up on people and see if they were
drinking or gambling with the assistance
that they were getting
from the state and in the united states
again it tracks back to the kind of
earliest versions of public assistance
programs that were out there
and
in the 20th century when we get uh
food stamps to predecessor to snap
uh the
kind of earliest food stamp uh
provisions included checking on people
to see if they were violating rules um
and there's it's a long history that's
intertwined uh there really is is almost
no uh historical period where welfare
programs did not include some kind of
suspicion checking evaluation types of
mechanisms
that said it certainly does ramp up uh
in the reagan administration in the
united states as a politically and
popularly salient issue and a period
when we get several key legal changes
so if a um certain program
has requirements in order to qualify
it seems intuitive that you would have
some mechanism for policing that and
ensuring that the people that are
getting the benefits actually qualify
now in in some theoretical sense
if
one eliminated all of this uh
bureaucracy for policing
there's some cost to that bureaucracy in
theory it might actually
in the net cost less not to worry about
the so-called free riders and eliminate
the cost of the bureaucracy has that
been studied with any particular
programs
uh so
economists have you know looked into
this at least to some degree with uh
regard to like a ubi type of system
right a universal basic income
uh the idea of you know taking a
means-tested program like snap like uh
tanf that we have now and completely
eliminating
the
expenses associated with the policing
mechanisms it's really hard to tell
you can do some things some very you
know basic you know back of the napkin
how much are we recovering per
investigation type of math but that does
not take account for whatever deterrent
effect the existence of fraud
investigation has
the
kind of broader symbolic uh components
of the system that have an influence on
people's behavior um which there is some
influence but it's really hard to
determine how it's uh you know the kind
of counterfactual where we don't have
these programs we don't have data really
right
so
it's tough to say and for the book i
uh the primary data are interviews with
people who work in fraud investigation
investigators and data analysts and
managers of these units and so forth and
they
you know
perhaps unsurprisingly given it's their
job but they think that that deterrent
effect which is hard to measure
is is really substantial so it's hard to
say
in uh in in policing by law enforcement
we
have many examples of how
a law or a statute can just kind of be
written
agnostically on paper but can be applied
in discriminatory ways or or selectively
can you talk a little bit about when it
comes to policing of welfare programs
does the same thing apply and if so how
do we see kind of the discriminate
discriminative application of some of
these programs or of policing mechanisms
rather
so there are ways uh that these programs
uh the way some of the ways that these
programs function
do have some implications i think for
inequities in who's investigated who's
uh you know potentially charged with
welfare fraud who has these charges
substantiated against them um you know i
will note that all the or nearly all of
the people that i spoke to were adamant
that they do not discriminate on the
basis of race they um you know have no
feelings about that one way or the other
uh you know one of the basic facts here
is that they mostly investigate women
because women are disproportionately
participants in the program right so
there's that uh there's that difference
i guess the question there would be are
they investigated at a greater rate than
their level of participation
uh they they don't keep statistics on
the characteristics of the people that
they investigate or at least they told
me that they don't so i can't say that
for sure i can say that
for example being
a person with children as opposed to a
person without children
has at least some effect on increasing
your likelihood of becoming the subject
of a serious investigation uh so
the
uh one of the basic mechanisms here is
the they're trying to figure out which
cases are most promising so they have
more potential investigations than they
can pursue so they choose which ones to
go after right one of the main things
that they're looking for
is a higher dollar value so if you're
the head of a household with children
you're probably getting a higher dollar
value in benefits than if you're not so
that's an example of a just kind of a
mathematical risk factor another
thing that's going on here is
the cases that are most promising to
investigate are cases with more
evidentiary availability right so if you
can get more information about a person
you're more likely to spend more time on
that investigation to make it a priority
because you can get more access to
evidence that you can use to
substantiate your charges so that means
if you are you know quote-unquote on
paper uh in various ways already with
government agencies whether that be
criminal justice agencies agencies of
the welfare state whatever it is if you
have kids in school
all these are potential sources of
information
uh that welfare fraud investigators can
draw upon to figure out how much money
you make who lives in your house these
kinds of things
so being more
recorded by the state uh has this sort
of implication of also making you
potentially more interesting as someone
to investigate because this evidence is
out there in ways it might not be for
someone who's less recorded with the
state when we talk about fraud um
people
oftentimes the application processes for
these programs are not particularly
simple
um and there's it seems to me at least
an intent a big difference between fraud
and errors made during the application
process can you talk a little bit about
whether mistakes and errors or
information that has since changed are
are considered fraud under this general
umbrella
um so i mean first i would flag though
the person whose research is probably
the best on this is karen gustafson who
wrote a book called cheating welfare
that's one of the inspirations for this
book that came out a few years ago
with nyu press and you know she focuses
on clients
and so she she delves pretty deeply into
this question of
intent and the construction of intent
and when is a mistake just a mistake
one thing that i can say for sure from
my
uh evidence and comparing it with
previous work like karen's that looks at
the the client side
is that the investigators are much more
likely to see things as intentional and
present them as intentional than our
clients right
and
that is in part due to the
structural factors pertaining here so
they are the individual investigators
and the broader units of which they are
parts are incentivized to
get intentional
program violation charges intentional
fraud charges those are the sort of most
rewarding for them professionally they
also garner
financial rewards for the state from the
federal government when you can uh
substantiate these types of charges so
uh there are things that i think are
borderline um that get constructed as
intentional and i mean the the broad
the you know the sort of baseline
understanding here is that if you
provide a piece of information to the
agency
uh and sign your application form saying
that everything that you've sworn to
here is accurate and up to date and then
later they find evidence whether it's
from the department of labor the
department of motor vehicles or a
privately maintained database of some
kind wherever they get it
if they find that evidence that
contradicts whatever you put on your
sign statement
that is generally considered probative
proof of
intentional fraud
and what is the process for adjudicating
something like that
so in 1976 uh the u.s supreme court
ruled in uh goldberg versus kelly that
welfare benefits are a form of property
uh and that therefore
uh participants in the program are
entitled to
some version of due process before
benefits can be terminated
um so the way that that works when
you're accused of an intentional program
violation is
in a setting that's called an
administrative hearing
uh administrative qualification hearing
perhaps uh that is overseen by an
administrative hearing officer that is
the equivalent of a judge
and that's where the client gets an
opportunity to come in and
potentially argue against uh whatever
allegations are being made present their
own evidence if they have evidence that
contradicts the evidence
that the welfare fraud investigator
gathered
and then the administrative hearing
officer makes a determination of whether
the state has met their
burden of proof in establishing you know
clear and convincing evidence of an
intentional program violation so that's
one of the things that welfare fraud
investigators have to learn how to
navigate and negotiate is
how to work in these settings getting to
know the particular hearing officers and
what kind of standards they have and
it's you know one sort of advantage that
a
fraud investigator has over a client is
they're more familiar with the setting
right they potentially know the hearing
officer they've been there before they
know
you know ms jones likes this kind of
evidence mr smith doesn't like this kind
of evidence right you know they're more
inclined to do this or that um so that's
the that's the setting where these
things are adjudicated and
one of the things that fraud
investigators learned is how to navigate
and negotiate in those spaces
one of the um
things i wanted to talk a little bit
about is
just other systems in other countries
that may overall be more efficient and
one could argue you know part of it
depends on your perspective but one
could argue that there's lots of
inefficiencies in in these systems one
could argue that the means testing
itself is an inefficiency one could
argue that the methods for policing are
inefficient
there's a lot of different approaches to
that but
in terms of benefits and cost efficiency
overall
what should we be aspiring to what sort
of examples in other countries are
particularly well run
uh so i'm not an expert on international
uh welfare states uh but i will say that
there is i think a very strong case to
be made for a universal basic income
type of system where you remove
all of this administrative overhead all
of this bureaucratic red tape and
create a much smoother flowing system
without all of these hurdles and
barriers and all the associated costs
and the you know expenses uh and so
people who are
uh experts in this area at least to the
extent that i've read them you know uh
generally
uh associate a system like ours that
focuses on means testing uh with the
almost inherent or uh
inescapable circumstance of
rule enforcement being a big part of it
right and this
process of determining who's in and
who's out being
a costly endeavor so in a system where
you can eliminate those
administrative expenses you're saving
that money so i think that there's a
definitely a good case to be made for
more of a uh
universal system so i mean something
like we have now in the united states
but just based on age right for social
security benefits and medicare benefits
in such a system
when both when it comes to ubi and
so-called free college
there's the criticism that you're also
giving stuff to the very very rich now
they're very very rich statistically are
a small percentage of of the economy by
by sort of definition is that something
we should worry about or not
well i mean i won't tell people what to
worry about or what to not worry about
but there
i mean there is an inherent logic to a
means-tested system right it makes a lot
of sense i think in an abstract world or
just you know on paper that people in
need should be the people that receive
things but it just gets very complicated
when you come down to the process okay
what is need right how are we gonna
calculate that that's contentious in and
of itself and then yeah these these
administrative costs i think
um they're often not visible publicly
right or not really prominent in the
popular imagination and again there is
this inherent logic to
targeting
aid to needy people
but where the rubber hits the road it's
a lot more complicated than just
see who's needy give it to them don't
give it to someone who's not yeah yeah
that's for sure that's for sure
the book is policing welfare punitive
adversarialism and public assistance
we've been speaking with the book's
author spencer headworth who's also
assistant professor of sociology at
purdue university
so great having you on today and really
appreciate your time
thanks david it was a pleasure